So two cases down, one third case to handle is if in fact
the first elements of x and y are not the same. To deal with this
case what we're going to do is we're going to carve up Y into three pieces, and
we're going to determine what those three pieces are based on where and
why the first element of X is. So, the first element of X is five.
Someplace in Y there is a five otherwise it's not a permutation. So
let's call the position of five in y the jth position and
our three segments are going to be from one up to J minus one. Second segment is
going to be the jth position all by itself and the third segment is going to
be the j plus first position all the way to the nth position.
The last position. Three segments and we are going to define whether or
not x and y are permutations in terms of those three segments.